[Music]
the world championship record is equals
lewis hamilton
wins the turkish grand prix and is a
seven-time
champion of the world i got goosebumps
you heard it's seven
time champion of the world that's
british formula one driver lewis
hamilton
who clinched an historic win on sunday
in istanbul with
94 career wins he has the most of any
driver in the history of the racing
series
whoa as the only black driver in formula
one he has taken a knee and stood up for
racial equality first on cbs this
morning
i love when we can say i'm going to say
it again first there he is on cbs this
morning
to discuss his victory in the fight for
change we welcome you lewis hamilton
i don't know if you can see me louis but
i'm wearing the mercedes color blue that
you all wear i'm so excited for you
so here i was i was cheering you on
sunday
on the upper west side i don't know if
you could hear me applauding
but you started in sixth position very
unusual for you
you started in sixth position and ended
up winning the race
take us there lois it was a crazy
weekend
and firstly thank you so much for having
me on and you know
you've been so supportive all these
years and it's a shame you can't come to
any of these races
this year obviously but i'm glad that we
got these races going
um sunday was it was hectic you know it
was
um the trickiest conditions it was
raining you like the rain though louis
louis you like the rain i do uh and we
started sixth
and i just wan honestly i just wanted to
go out and have fun and i had no idea
what would happen but of course i always
have that belief that i can make it
to the front but uh all these obstacles
came and
um i did 50 laps on one set of tires
which is i guess
very unusual you even ignored the team
telling you come in and change tires you
didn't do that but listen lap 37
you took the lead 37 out of 58 you took
the lead you never looked back
but this is the thing that struck me
when you pulled in and you won normally
you hop
out of the car you greet your team you
greet your crew
but you said in the car it was clearly a
very emotional moment for you
what were you thinking at that moment
honestly i um you know i've been racing
for 27 years and
it's always been a dream to be not only
in for one but to
i watched michael schumacher win those
seven world titles and
it was such a far-fetched dream but i
kept believing that i could potentially
get there but
he had the highs and the lows and i
think as i came across the line
the build up over that last lap was you
know the fact that it was right
right in front of me i just got to stay
on the track don't make mistakes keep
believing in yourself and i did
all the way and so i just burst out in
tears as i came across the line
and i just couldn't get out the car
because i was i just couldn't believe it
you know and
were you thinking about your dad too
yeah just
thinking about you know a lot of my life
i've kind of flashed
before my eyes and particularly just
knowing that my dad worked so hard
you know at one stage you know having
four jobs and just having such belief
i felt like i finally i finally
accomplished what we set out to do
and uh and hopefully he feels that it
was worth
the the hard work well 14 years ago you
started as the only black race card
driver in formula one 14 years later you
are still the only black
race car driver in formula one and you
write this you said being the first
black anything is a proud and lonely
walk
help us understand what it's been like
for you
yeah well i mean we started out you know
as i said back in 1992 or 93
and um we were we were always the only
black family on the scene
and honestly i thought that us being
there by the time i got to formula one i
thought me just being there
would break down barriers would open up
doors and encourage
uh it to be a more diverse sport but
i realized last year after 14 years
that that has barely shifted and so
um now you're speaking out about this
lewis now you're speaking out yeah
i think it was difficult i tried to
speak about it in the past but it was
always
you know there was always a bit of
pushback and it wasn't the easiest thing
to speak about but i think
particularly this year with the black
lives matter movement it there's been an
awakening and
an opportunity to use your voice and i
felt such a responsibility
to my niece and nephew who are biracial
to all the young kids
particularly the you know black and the
minorities out there that
that potentially feel they don't have a
voice i was like i've got to use this
platform
to help encourage and you know no one's
doing the homework to find out why our
sport is not diverse
so i put together a commission to really
try and find out what
what the barriers are and see how we can
find a fundamental
you know find find a real platform to be
able to
open up the doors for young black kids
to get into stem
and engineering and you've challenged
you challenged mercedes you've asked
them some very tough questions but your
contract is up that contract
negotiations and
negotiations are underway i love toto
wolfe too who's a principal owner
should toto back up the truck or are you
thinking
let's discuss this fellas because you
know they're rumors that you're thinking
about walking away
10 seconds lewis i love i love doing
what i'm
i'm doing and i honestly winning the
seventh world title is an incredible
thing but i think we've still not won
this fight for racial
equality and so this